well the new look albert pujols is in a
dodger uniform number 55. a 10-time
all-star a three-time mvp one of the
greatest ever to do it he'll start at
first base and back cleanup tonight
and tonight's going to be walker bueller
on the mound for the dodgers and the
left-handed hitting pavemen smith is
leading off fastball gets him looking
took him made pitches but he rings up
smith for the first out tonight strike
three on the curve first ball right down
the middle and right at the bottom of
the strike zone peralta is the hitter at
273 and a toss over to first base and
back with a head first slide
is josh
is
rojo
wouldn't have to move the data wins
again
bottom of the first inning madison bub
gardner on the mountain for the d-backs
jammed them
foul ground third base side escobar has
got it
there's turner one more time for eduardo
that gives way to nick ahmed pop ups and
two outs for mad bod comes max muncie
look at the big fella on deck looking
forward to his first at-bat in the
dodger uniform 3-1 muncie
watches ball four
and that will get albert pujols to the
plates
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the greatest ever to do it fifth
and home runs with 666
third in rbis more than 2 000 a 10-time
all-star a three-time mvp
making his dodger debut
attacks the first pitch and sends one
way up there to left center
they got under it the castro made the
catch but
that had that sound didn't it no score
here in the second up comes the
shortstop nick ahmed 2-2
got him swinging a 1-2-3 second for
walker builder we talk about the impact
of bringing albert pujols into the
clubhouse and having a hall of famer
like that around got to be so many pinch
me moments for some of the younger
players like will smith who grew up
idolizing him
[Music]
[Applause]
well he makes a swing like albert here
high fast ball meets it perfectly
we'll give it a ride first home run this
month for will smith it's a beauty
muncie likes it i guess so so sugo likes
it yoshi in the foreground now you know
the uh ring ceremony on opening day
where everybody had their favorite
player
to record a video for him and this could
present the ring to him albert pujols
was will smith hey will avra pujo is
here i just want to take this moment to
congratulate you on winning the world
series last year continue to work hard
really proud of you god bless you
brother and now he's protecting him in
the lineup exactly two on with one out
and the guy that drew the first walk of
the day max muncie that back-to-back
curves this one he accused the third
escobar with a high throw
to lead to the one out bet's dancing his
way off third making sure that ahmed
pays attention from gunner visibly
frustrated that they couldn't turn to
there escobar was kind of a wrong foot
throw kind of gets his feet tangled a
little bit trying to get out of it quick
ahmed with the tag
bumgarner with the reaction so first and
third two gone out comes albert pujols
the all-time rbi leaderboard goes babe
ruth hank aaron albert pujols 212.
he's got a couple more ducks on the pond
here with two gone in the third
he hits a ground ball base hit in the
center field
albert pujols brings home mookie bets
for the los angeles dodgers
how cool
his quote at the press conference was i
still have some gasoline left in the
tank and he sure does
brought a buzz into the locker room when
they heard about the signing and now
brings a buzz here
at dodger stadium with all the dodger
fans cheering this first rbi as a los
angeles dodger
[Music]
2113 driven in his first in blue and the
pitch of the runners going and the
ground ball to short ahmed's got it
he'll throw to first slow and a nice
scoop there by payment smith he saved
nick and air on that one and goes all
the way to the bag and touches gloves
with
pavement smith thanking him scubar will
lead it off here as we go to the
diamondback fourth inning he came up and
got smith snuck under the mask we're
balling the dirt now the angle the
bounce yeah oh right up under there and
gets him in the chin will made sure that
possum couldn't visit for real long kind
of a little camera time that's right
walks the base is loaded well it's kind
of a good and bad thing the bad part is
he's walked three in a row the good
thing is there's one area that he has
been pitching to and that's high so is
this you would think it's just a
mechanical adjustment strike somehow
nothing but sliders
to get on there two gone not out of the
woods yet tim lo castro flight out his
first time the castro pops it off the
end of the bat to ride bets is there and
bueller finds it and gets out of the jam
top of the order paving smith third time
through for arizona
sharply head months is there to his feet
to it
making his fourth start of the season
his second base
and a sharp play there for out number
two little sliding
get to your feet
find the range
albert in the chest well done a little
smaller glove when you're playing second
base throw it over to the big glove
walker bueller on to the sixth inning
leading to nothing only one hit against
walker builder today bigger issue has
been the walks is issued for them
eduardo escobar leads it off and flies
it to left
one pitch
that'll bring up david peralta
swinging to miss right three two gone
strikeout number seven four bueller and
two quick outs here on the diamondbacks
sixth inning
attacks the first pitch into center
field peters is there
and that's the ending you blink
and it's over they're gonna put peters
on intentionally to get the pitcher's
spot to the plate and walker bueller
who's thrown 90 pitches will hit for
himself swinging strike three so caleb
gets out of it two strikeouts in the end
and they'll leave three walker bueller
for the first time in his career walk
three consecutive batters
and it was with one out in the fourth
but dealer has retired all eight batters
he's faced since
that's over
and you're going to be working now to
the middle of the diamondbacks lineup
beginning with eduardo escobar the
switch hitter
hits it to short that gets through lux
here comes pavon it's a 2-1 ball game
time run 90 feet away kenley janssen
coming on the season with men on base
kelly jansen holding opponents to two
for 27. ground ball ricochets off the
mound turner pivots and threes to get
him
game saving play justin turner two outs
smith leads from third dodgers two to
one bottom of the eighth on 2-2 lux
yanks basic to right to bring home smith
and give him the run right back
and the dodgers get a big insurance run
leading at three to royal voice
in the back i'm not sure he's ever made
it out they're down there there's like
three guys giving him the scouting
report muncie turner
turner's laughing i can't believe he's
getting advice can't get the right
helmet on albert's there
the braley's got too small ahead mark
pryor's laughing behind him he's
look we stalled for you to get ready to
come in we're going to stall for you to
get the right helmet
now get back to what he's paid to do two
on and one out and here's the guy that's
had a flare for the dramatic hit it's
andrew young the battery the o2
it is a breaking ball he left it up and
a bounce to rocks
six four three
three one